youtube direct sie gegen selbstmord so
sehen es jedenfalls die medien dabei hat
sie eine krankheit umgebracht ursache
dafür waren depressionen eine wirklich
heimtückische krankheit während
depressionen eine infektionskrankheit
mit schweren körperlichen auswirkungen
würde was einen fieberhaft nach einem
impfstoff gesucht werden das ist aber
nicht der fall und geht wahrscheinlich
auch gar nicht und so sterben jedes jahr
allein in deutschland rund 10.000
menschen an dieser krankheit warum hat
sich die you tube ihn umgebracht und was
hilft gegen depressionen jetzt richtig
zum zweiten wechsel erzwingen
wer oder die ein oder andere hat
vielleicht schon mitbekommen ich kümmere
mich auch um die dattel täter ein ganz
toller kanal hier auf youtube der gerade
zwei grimme online award gewonnen hat
und den smart joel ward von facebook und
der stiftung digitale chancen
auch von ihr aus noch mal herzlichen
glückwunsch bei der verleihung des
master award bin ich auf ein wirklich
tolles projekt gestoßen
freunde fürs leben ein verein der sich
darum kümmert dass depressionen erkannt
und behandelt werden denn leider gibt es
nur wenige die sich darum kümmern im
moment stehen krebs oder aids mehr im
mittelpunkt dabei sterben an
depressionen 20 mal mehr menschen als
einzige service wirklich so eine
krankheit allen ist sie unangenehm und
keiner will sich kaum kümmern und das
ist auch so furchtbar sechs betroffene
wollen es oft nicht wahrhaben begeben
sich nur zögerlich in behandlung oder
nehmen die medikamente nicht die
krankheit ist wirklich schlimm
die übernimmt regelrecht bewegt von den
erkrankten und die gesellschaftliche
ächtung trägt dann noch ihren teil dazu
bei
gibt es überhaupt keinen grund menschen
mit dieser krankheit zu echten oder so
verurteilt depressionen sind eben eine
krankheit die vermutlich durch vererbung
infektionen drogen hormone
schwangerschaft und weitere ursachen
ausgelöst wird den oder die erkrankte
trifft dabei keinerlei schuld trotzdem
werden sie oft eben verurteilt und
gemieden und bei uns in der
medienindustrie in depressionen
besonders ausgeprägt oft spielt dann
auch noch drogenkonsum eine rolle und
löst die depression so aus oder versteht
matthias ist wirklich ganz furchtbar in
meinem umfeld sind schon drei menschen
dadurch umgekommen und ich sage das
jetzt an dieser stelle ganz bewusst weil
selbstmord oder suizid für mich ihre
falsche wurde die krankheit hat die
menschen umgebracht und so ist es jetzt
auch die wie ryanair gang auslöser für
ihren freitod war der tod ihres
großvaters das war einfach zu viel für
sie und sie hat es nicht mehr
ausgehalten viele rhein erreichte mit
ihren videos millionen zuschauer
aber wie wir alle hat auch sie einen
hohen preis dafür bezahlt im mittelpunkt
zu stehen ist auch leider immer mit viel
hass verbunden
rhein sagte dazu einmal es ist ganz egal
wer du bist du kannst die talentierteste
personen aus der ganzen welt sein aber
wenn du irgendwas im internet
veröffentlicht hat erfüllte reaktions
erst kurz vor ihrem tod hat sie die
auswirkungen des verlustes ihres
großvaters noch in einem podcast
beschrieben in mentell i kill ein
podcast über depression sagte sie dass
sie hoffe dass sein tod wie nicht noch
tiefer in die depression slider ist das
geschehen
ich kann nur sagen wenn ihr in eurem
freundeskreis jemand bemerkt der
dauerhaft schlecht drauf ist antriebslos
und so weiter informiert euch über die
krankheit und hält und auch wenn er
selbst den verdacht habt unter
depressionen zu leiden geht einfach zum
hausarzt ist erst mal eine ganz normale
krankheit und er oder sie kann euch dann
weiterhelfen tolles natürlich auch der
verein freunde fürs leben den link dazu
habe ich in die video beschreibung passt
dann kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen und
hier können der klicks um ein abo aufs
auge drücken und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocken ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran